because usually I'm just focused on my
lines and not actually the stuff that's
written around I'm like who they're
supposed to be for there are so many
music references I don't I'm not into
music I don't keep up with that oh I
don't like combi doesn't make me laugh
Tina that's not funny hello they reject
nation I'm Greg elbows I'm John Bailey
was up we have epic voice guy himself of
honest trailers and many many other
things how it should have ended movie
trailers in it of itself cartoon your
work I can't figure out which thing you
might have worked on before recently
you heard me as TJ Miller in the
underwater trailer what yeah I don't
believe you yeah that was me I don't
believe that was cooking baked for me to
talk about avocados having sex with
older avocados TJ Miller's voice no
biggie
whatever alright let's watch screen
junkies honest truth or sure will be
hilarious they do these like spoof
trainer you might have heard them before
you haven't actually so cinemasins like
yeah they countdown every mistake but
you haven't actually seen oh I I rarely
get a chance to watch them after I
record them first time yeah I've not
seen yet this summer we're getting
honest about summer blockbusters past
and present this is honest trailers
blockbusters summer use the Blockbuster
Video pot nice Mabel pines you love
2014's Godzilla for the few minutes you
could actually see Godzilla
get ready for a sequel that heard your
demands and massively over compensate
more godzilla who has atomic breath to
thumbs in this is movie title this guy
that was one of my endless the teeth of
he does have thumbs doesn't he like he
does he owns king of the monsters let's
grab it
for two long hours of non-stop kaiju
hygiene that you could almost see when
they're not obscured by blizzards you're
sorry hiding behind waterfalls submerged
beneath the ocean flying through debris
and whatever is happening good old days
I better bring that movie back look I'm
really sorry guys you gonna have to
Brussels your typical nuclear family
I've Nicholas a genocidal back 11 is too
good for a goes now and dad is a
professional animal listen to follow
their time-tested love story as boy
meets girl boy in girl they buy
overthink acoustic device to talk to
whales that's of gods it's Google
reapplies will take to control kaiju boy
gets drunk invisible dwarves and Tony
Stark's cabbage oh wow graboids monster
to enhance its power
alright hold up all that stuff happens
in this movie how was it still so boring
true story
sigh has it cast with six heavies and
five Oscar nominations between them
tackles a big-budget sharknado where
Sally Hawkins has killed off in the
blink of an eye people in seas now Ken
Watanabe tries to say Godzilla as many
times as they can before dying when she
and Charles dance is also present
leaving brilliant actors with nothing to
do but track down giant monsters they'll
do track and study Godzilla on his own
turn
we lost Godzilla dropped off the skin
they're men as well they've washed up on
driveway
[Music]
this is the stairs song is bad guys it's
the flare snare song they first did this
in Star Trek I think Star Trek the song
that we need is every time there's flare
there are a lot of stairs
see some things you just can't
appreciate till you see it
record beer in but you don't see what
they're gonna do with it
well there's your two hours worth right
there have so Streb that underwhelmed
audiences and disappointed at the box
office but since Godzilla vs. Kong is
already in production the franchise is
literally too big to fail true story
we're giving it no matter what no real
album is corporate inertia bump so much
funnier arse parts kaiju typical guy
Jewish mother we die alone
why didn't you just miss these monsters
respect the original they put her in a
tiny seashell I'd have given Godzilla
third movie if I could you have
butterfly
Mothra baby Mexico Wild Wings franchise
building these things are there
seventeen and the bigger the shining let
them fight club how I see what they did
all my science knowledge comes from
watching Chernobyl
everything's rated rouen really really
bad right yeah now we just we nuclear
fallout attention campers
lunch has been canceled today due to
like a puzzle deal with it
words are hard fortunately I don't speak
for a living
unfortunately it's not true after the
they cut the end of that comment off and
it says like the way you say bewbs wait
for these last ones you just record a
month's worth in advance no they only
give me like three at a time and I don't
get totally there I don't get I have no
say in what they [ __ ] what they pick I
do use my voice for a live a speak for a
living that's natural well the next time
is people the next time you're coming on
I'm gonna put out a comment what do you
want him to say I'm just gonna I'll say
you're conveyed obese whole hours
nothing the comments ten hours straight
of comments I mean those videos do
really well right I think they are the
highest performing I mean there's some
great points here there's some really
good points Godzilla king of the
monsters is one of those movies where
whatever people complain about I'm
always like yeah a hundred percent agree
I just happen to sway towards a side of
like I think there's a solid chunk in
the middle that's pretty dull and pretty
boring where it's like really human base
but I do think like the first half hours
really entertaining and I think that uh
I think it's really cool the first you
not on a TV screen in the background
this big that's true but there's a solid
point about the monsters being so
obscure lead in the first movie -
there's like continuing this not showing
us anything it's all hidden what I would
argue is that in the in the first movie
though that creates sort of this like
looming ominous sort of tension in like
true what's going on and then here this
is the one that's like no we're gonna
show you the monster actually their face
except you still can't really see what's
going on there's
three different kinds going on a same
time although it always made for like
great trailer moments even watching
you're watching it back now so that was
freaking crazy I saw it in 40 X 40 so
that's the kind of movie yeah it is
crazy you're having like an epileptic
seizure
yeah the humans are are boring they just
seem like they're running in there that
stairs a lot of stars to be that boring
big names they said like like Emmys and
Oscar winners all oh it's so Freeman and
yet so boring
they beat the SH in Godzilla I really
like that one and that one is has super
interesting characters like great
characters so thing they have none the
only character we've even established
most about is got true and the most
interesting human character has been
Bryan Cranston hey Davey blueseed him I
think yeah Wiggly and then he's not even
in this whole thing with the stairs I
think is really funny because I did
really some when I watched the film of
like this it's trying to develop some
like sense of wonder but it's not
succeeding in that department and for
the belt a little background so that
song that they use during the stairs
part that is a running gag on honest
trailers they may have started before
Star Trek but I know for a fact it
became the most popular because of the
flares it was that one winds flares not
stairs but these the same song
[Music]
I wasn't the Twilight one it might have
been twilight farthest right before I
said start to exhibit while I may have
been at first stares
[Music]
see I didn't do all the Twilight movies
that was another voice that did some of
those before we will not talk about him
that song has become infamous for flares
and stares
honestly I guess I didn't realize there
was that much staring in the movie until
I pointed it out into into a bond tars
anything cut from so there was a lot cut
a lot of the times on on the script I'll
get a lot of alternate lines and usually
you can see those in the honest
commentaries where they just do the
complete uncut audio of me doing all the
stuff in a row but for the starring
section there's huge chunks the one I
thought that was the best that they
didn't use was can want to not be in
this movie anymore and I can't believe
it because I was like that's so much fun
he's really dying about the fact that
who has tooth them who has atomic breath
two thumbs and it's a movie title this
guy their version did not include the
two thumbs but well you can't say that
phrase but who's got two thumbs this guy
he's like does he he's got claws Mike no
he's got freakin hands he doesn't have
four fingers but he's got two thumbs and
three fingers that's how he's able to
clones them he doesn't have like Raptor
like t-rex arms he's like yeah he does
have two thumbs
I had lib you know maybe three to half a
dozen jokes in a thing and maybe one out
of that might make it it I never know
until I actually watch them which
sometimes I don't have time to catch up
now a Godzilla vs. Kong coming out I'm
kind of worried about some Justice
League sort of issues because the gods
are king of monsters really did not
perform well at the box office it's
pretty much a box office but they have
Godzilla vs. Kong coming out right and
I'm kind of worried that are gonna do
some drastic rewrites for production
costs anything about it when your
predecessor fails at the box office
they're gonna be like we got to trim
down some money on this next guy I guess
you yeah
can totally get in a Batman vs Superman
situation let's spin the movie of these
two characters and why they have to
fight and then all sudden let's give
them another bad guy to fight together
they're basically both hero characters
to a lot of people a lot of people think
king kong is a good guy and Godzilla's a
good guy having them fight is one thing
but they have to turn on something I
have to they have to team up against
something else at some point or else
somebody's gonna lose the director said
that there will be a definitive winner
fight between them and see I don't like
that idea
oh yeah to be like you know
brofist and at the end I want to see a
buddy cop movie with clones the good I
feel like it would be pretty cool of
Kong actually won because he has to save
the world and also nuclear destroyed it
the Kong movies he's always killed us
true but he was defending his territory
and his people he was protecting his
family I mean not Kong Skull Island but
whenever he's browsing what's going what
he's brought to America he's he was
dragged and put placed into captivity
and enslaved you kind of justified his
reaction should survive the hit he she
kills a gorilla and he survives he's
like helped to though I don't know I get
[ __ ] what I've wanted to be a bleak
ending that's what I'm trying to tell
you right now I want a moment more for a
Rakhi thing like they end up being
framed
I don't think and then he can either one
of us like the next well guys we've
[Laughter]
thank you guys for being here thank you
John Bale a pleasure man here you guys
can subscribe to screen chunks you could
subscribe to rejects quick notification
bells check out john bailey on twitter
instagram i think he has a unique voice
yeah across the thing hey speaking of
that epic voice guy john bailey let me
use your talents once more we got a
patron here named Brianna davidson
alrighty she loves John Humphrey
obsessed
Humphry loves his reactions as a kid who
watches our Channel and our patron for
anime reactions any of that little
information I gave you work with with
your voice what was her name again it
was a lot of Infirmary Brianna in a
world where Brianna Davidson was in love
with John Humphries together they'll
make many magical moments together but
only in her imagination imaginary
boyfriend Rita BG 13 starts Friday on
patreon everywhere yes where else you
gonna get that shout out Brianna without
a John Humphrey me